(cris des manifestants)
- C'est vraiment courageux.
- Depuis près d'un mois
maintenant, Nika, 17 ans,
suit les manifestations en Iran,
son paysgrâce à son téléphone.
- Le gouvernement a vraiment
diminué l'internet, alors c'est
vraiment difficile pour les gens
é
par des femmes, des jeunes
comme elle, comme Mahsa Amini,
morte en détention après avoir
enfreint le code vestimentaitre,
sont devenues le symboled'une ce
contre le régime islamique.
- L'intention derrièret pas juse
le hijab, c'est les droits
des femmes : le droit des femmes
de se divorcer de leur mari,rrrr
leurs enfants après
un divorce...es
ces raisons que sahar,
a quitté l'Iran et son ex-mari.e
habite dans une mtion
que moi, vive les mêmesi.i.i.i..
- C'est des filles qui peuvent
pas montrer leur face.n mainten,
je ferai chose que
les autres. C'est quand même de.
- Nimâussi voudrait
être à leur côté. Remplie
d'espoir malgré lautres
mouvements de soulèvement
qu'a déjà connu le pays.
NIMÂ MACHOUF, membre de l'Asso.
femmes iraniennes  est un pays
multiculturel, beaucoup...
plusieurs langues, plusieurs
cultures, plusieurs ethnies,
tout ça.à chaquà chaquà chaquà e
les uns contre les autres.
Ils n'ont pas réussi.
Retourner en arrière
- Près d'un mois après le début
des premières manifestatio
l'ex-président du Parlement
a critiqué la réaction de l'État
les manifestants.
- C'est des soupapes de
sécurité, c'est une manière
aussi de rester au pouvoir.
selon cette politologue.
HANIEH ZIAEI, Observatoire,rvat,
Chaire Raoul-Dandurand, UQAM
- Je pense que fondamentalement,
en question. L'idée, c'est pas
d'aller  des miettes
à une population, c'est
véritablement apporter
économique, culturelle.
té, vous avez une
population qui lutte pour la
démocratie, et vous avez, dei le
pour sauvegarder ses privilègese
l'élite, c'est ce qu'Ottawa fait
avec de nouvelles qui a tué
ses propres citoyens.
- Le gouvernement Trudeau a
ajouté 17 personnes et 3 entités
associés
islamique d'Iran, pour qui
il est interdit d'enter au pays
et de fa
les entreprises canadiennes.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Mon